what if a plateau is a launching pad
when I started running it was the first
time I was made aware of my internal
conversation of like the actual thoughts
whether it was like in first person or
third person that were going on in
between my ears and I was
brought back to that in that training
cycle postpartum
as my ability to either use the words to
cat what kind of spell am I going to
cast with the words that are going on
internally and it was either going to be
I had a choice like are you going to
berate yourself for the size of these
pants or are you going to tell yourself
oh my God like you are outside you have
your husband's able to watch the baby
she's healthy like you're healed enough
from this post-c section to even lace up
you know you were craving to even get
Outdoors you know so there was an
element of gratitude and kindness that I
had to incorporate into that training
cycle and it ended up being the best
four months of training of my life